[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so salis welt
heute dachte ich ich mach mal murat eine
freude und bargeld orte aber weil das
sich immer beschwert dass ich so viele
süße torten backe backe ich heute
einfach eine herzhafte torte und war
gefüllt mit zurück hier habt ihr eine
pizza torte ja die gibt es wirklich und
im innern sieht es so aus das sind also
verschiedene schichten oder mehrere
schichten und im prinzip ist es eine
viel 140 habe pfizer böden im prinzip
ist es ein zusammenspiel zwischen einer
normalen hitzer und einer calzone weil
im inneren backt im prinzip alles so wie
in der kantone richtig lecker das ganze
habe ich mit meinen grund rezepten
zubereitet aber ich zeige mich dennoch
ganz kurz wie ich den pizzateig gemacht
habe und zeigt euch hier vorne mal die
zutaten für den pizzateig brauche ich
500 milliliter warmes wasser einen
halben würfel hefe das sind 21 gramm
zwei esslöffel zucker 900 gramm mehl 2
teelöffel salz sechs esslöffel olivenöl
und etwas pfeffer
ich werde jetzt den hefeteig zubereiten
dafür früher ich zuerst einmal das
wasser
gemeinsam mit der hefe und dem zucker in
einer großen schüssel
ihr könnt den teig dann entweder mit der
hand verkneten oder einfach so wie ich
die küchenmaschine verwenden
anschließend gebe ich jetzt noch das
mehl das salz das olivenöl und eine
prise pfeffer hinzu und verkehrte den
teig für etwa sieben bis zehn minuten
geschmeidig wenn der teig dann
geschmeidig ist nehme ich ihnen heraus
und formen einfach mit den händen
zusammen zu einer kugel und das geht am
besten wenn ihr die hände vorher ein
bisschen mit olivenöl oder zb bakterien
spray ein fettes
und jetzt gebe ich ein bisschen olivenöl
in die schüssel dank und dateien und den
welt sichert so ein bisschen was mit dem
öl bedeckt ist und jetzt kann ich ihnen
für eine stunde bei raumtemperatur
aufgehen lassen
der teig ist jetzt aufgegangen und jetzt
nehme ich ihnen heraus und kann ihn
einfach dünn ausrollen und jetzt kann
ich hier kreise ausstechen und zwar
nehme ich jetzt einen parkring mit 18
zentimetern durchmesser und pro torte
brauchen mitunter etwa vier bis fünf
böten aber ich muss auch noch ein
bisschen was übrig lassen denn ich koche
auch noch einen rand
so wird schon sieben teig würden
rausbekommen den rest habe ich jetzt
wieder zusammen geknetet ich lasse ihn
kurz ruhen damit ich ihnen gleich wieder
in ruhe aus rollen kann man sich einfach
ein bisschen elastischer und die
tottenham tor und die pizza böden die
kann ich jetzt mit einer gabel mehrmals
einstechen und dann müssen die
vorgebacken werden damit sie einfach in
der torte später nicht so matschig
werden und vor backen tue ich die pizza
würden jetzt im vorgeheizten backofen
bei 200 grad ober unterhitze für etwa
acht bis neun minuten und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich schon mal die
tomatensauce und die füllung zu bereiten
für die tomatensoße brauche ich 800
gramm tomaten aus der dose 200 gramm
tomatenmark ich habe ich noch gewürze
und zwar ein teelöffel sei es einen
halben teelöffel chili eine prise zucker
2 esslöffel oregano und basilikum 2
knoblauchzehen und etwas pfeffer
die soße ist ziemlich einfach zubereitet
ihr müsst nämlich einfach nur alle
zutaten verrühren
tomatenmark mit nein die knoblauchzehen
werde ich noch fein reiben und dann
kommen noch die gewürze mit regen
[Musik]
ein bisschen tomatensoße kriegt jetzt
die sanierung auf ihre pizza und die
restliche tomatensoße werde ich hier in
einen topf füllen und ein bisschen
einkochen lassen weil sie einfach sehr
wässrig ist und der die pizza torte ist
besser wenn es eben nicht so sehr
besorgt also hier eingeben und dann etwa
zehn minuten lang köcheln lassen
jetzt sind die teige vorgebacken und ich
hab sie einfach übereinander gestapelt
und haben sich so ein bisschen
aufgeblasen aber ich hab es einfach
wieder runter gedrückt den restlichen
tag habe ich noch mal kurz ruhen lassen
und jetzt nochmal dünn ausgerollt und
eher länglich und den werde ich jetzt
einmal mittig halbieren gleich zwei
torten mache jetzt habe ich hier die
tomatensoße bereits stehen ich habe als
füllung noch etwas büffel mozzarella di
habe ich ein paar peperoni und natürlich
morath favorit so job und da müsste
jetzt einfach drauf achten dass ihr
zutaten habt ihr nicht so verbessern
also spinat und champignons eignen sich
jetzt nicht so gut daher eher trockenen
zutaten nehmen jetzt wenn ich das ganze
in einem bug ring back und das ist einer
mit 18 cm durchmesser da jetzt gefettet
entweder mit bakterien spray oder mit
olivenöl und jetzt nehme ich den einen
teig strang
am besten legt ihr denn hin es geht
bisschen einfach auf und dann kann ich
den hier an den rand drücken
[Musik]
am ende das einfach ein bisschen
zusammenrücken und vor allem oben so ein
bisschen überstehen lassen mich da ganz
vorsichtig machen
jetzt lege ich hier den ersten
vorgebackenen teig hinein und wenn der
beim backen ein bisschen zu groß
geworden ist können wir ihn einfach
nochmal zu schneiden und jetzt wird das
ganze gefüllt zuerst kommt tomatensoße
rein dann ein bisschen sawtschuk
peperoni und käse
[Musik]
jetzt kommt die zweite teig schicht
drauf und so wird jetzt die komplette
torte gefüllt bis ich fertig bilden
drinnen habe
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den letzten boden drin da
kommt jetzt noch mal tomatensoße
[Musik]
peperoni und zum abschluss käse habe
gehört du bist gekommen als ich hier
diese ist immer traumhaft irgendwann nur
noch auf 14
das klingt bietet die frau ist daheim
und machten sich kurator ist hier
wahrscheinlich kennt unsere kleine farm
vielleicht lernen überhaupt auch nur so
eine ganze familie und alle waren nett
zueinander und mitt romney was ja wohl
überträgt feuerschein und jetzt schlage
ich hier noch die ränder 1
das wird dann sozusagen der rand der
pizza davon hatte doch schon immer
geträumt oder kann es noch einmal mehr
zuschauer nicht geschrieben dass es doch
gar nicht sein kann dass es immer
familie so harmonisch zu geben er
wirklich ist stimmt das hat die wirklich
geschrieben und es kann nicht sein dass
ein spiel in der familie ist es nicht
haben wir nicht bestimmte es ist
wirklich nicht so harmonisch meine zeit
halt einfach die sachen die nebenher
laufen
ich bin einfach nicht ja ich meine ich
kenne auch nächste mal die kamera
auspacken wenn wir uns streiten aber
insgesamt ist das immer harmonisch
hauptsache am ende verträgt man sich
wieder so
diese leckere pizza torte
ich finde es immer noch seltsam dieses
herzhafte gerichte pizza torte zu nennen
diese pizza torte kommt jetzt in den
backofen den habe ich bereits vorgeheizt
auf 200 grad ober unterhitze und da wird
sie gebacken für etwa 25 bis 30 minuten
die zähne schöne kruste hat
morath rechte zu lieb und wird im
backofen schließen meine hände sind
träger ich fühle ich meine dinge ordnen
natürlich so danke mannschaft und wer
schon noch sein leben wird noch die
küche säubern natürlich meinen schatz
durch auch vielleicht den müll
rausbringen das palais war das wirklich
so glücklich machen
[Musik]
was möchtest du probieren sie es jetzt
schon eingestellt sagt peter bizer
trocken also schon gesagt weil du dich
immer beschwert weil es halt immer nur
süße torten gibt gibt's jetzt mal die
kafka und tom spricht ja eigentlich
nicht also eigentlich so viel zeit mit
pizza belegt
ja genau
ok jetzt schon zusammenschluss von
calzone und yamaha mit sonst würde es
jetzt in der messe haben ja einfach
besser war gut ich hab jetzt
bereitgestellt berichtet man muss ja
auto zu sagen es war auch ein wunsch
rezepte und ich wollte dir einfach mal
eine freude machen nicht gesehen
das ist so wie fingernägel an der tafel
ich glaube jetzt fährt jedes um schauer
über den rücken
und wie schmeckte nein
an dieser erwarten sind ich bin halt
keine überraschung also geschlechtliche
es ist cool
eine überraschung wäre es wenn ich noch
eine von land decke drüber hätte aber
ich komme vom machen ja da bin ich mal
im bereich die gäste
ich finds aufholen sondern mit rollator
oder party und zum nachtisch gibt orte
wo schmeckt der halle mit foto ganz
schön würde ganz ehrlich immer ein
deutsches produkt gemacht also ich hätte
gar nicht schlecht schnitten können und
war das jetzt ein held
es war ein löwe lobte of the box also
falls er das rezept auch gerne
ausprobieren möchtet dann schaut auf
meinem blog vorbei auch cds - blog.de
das ganze könnt ihr auch gerne
vegetarisch zu bereiten da würde ich zum
beispiel getrocknete tomaten mit rein
geben die sind wirklich super würzig und
wie gesagt keine zutaten wie zu viel
wasser enthalten
von daher unter schillingen guten
appetit weil es soll er nicht matschig
werden
ja und das ist nicht mein chef nein
absolut nicht matschig und der sich die
kunst des toten zu beklagen
also viel spaß beim nachkochen guten
appetit und das wird das nächste mal
wohl zu drücken
ja oder nehmt euch einfach so türk aus
unserer vorratskammer aus unserem
kühlschrank kamerun gewehr 50 hektar was
man will zeigen wie kann ich aber jetzt
machen morath gedanken muss den vorrat
aufstocken und hat ihr job für montag
zurück für dienstag mittwoch und es wird
einfach nicht weniger ich glaube morgen
gibt es nochmals druck und den ganzen
nächsten monaten
[Musik]
danke mein schatz und wer schon noch so
lieb und wird noch die küche sauber
natürlich wünscht sich auch vielleicht
den müll rausbringen das palais war das
wirklich so glücklich machen danke
[Gelächter]